my name is Brian John Jude and I manage
the arts humanities and social science
curriculum here at Khan Academy so I was
the first person in my family to attend
college and I remember my freshman year
the first course I was taking was in
literature in history and we were
reading a primary source and it was
talking about the Norman invasion in
1066 and I remember reading the Normans
took a boat from France to England and I
remember thinking why would they take a
boat why wouldn't they just walk and so
I went home and I opened a map and I
realized oh my gosh
because England's an island and I had
just my history education was so subpar
in high school here I was a
first-generation college student in a
class my freshman year thinking I don't
belong here
I don't even know that England is an
island so I had two choices in front of
me I could have quit and acknowledged
that I don't belong here I shouldn't be
in this course or I could ask for help
at least 10 times a day
which is what I did I went to office
hours I got help from the librarians who
gave me extra books to read and
recommended books on course and I mean
really I was craving a resource like
Khan Academy because I knew I had these
gaps and I needed someone to help me
fill them I really struggled with my
writing and so I was at the Writing
Center almost every day in college
recognizing that I needed to get better
and I could just avoid writing or avoid
those courses or say I know this is
gonna be hard and the way that I'm gonna
get through it is by asking for help by
admitting my own humility and knowing
what I don't know and just signing
myself up for the struggle